welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
identifying pattern transitions of mind
and brain in psychotherapy the nonlinear
dynamics of human change processes it is
presented by Gunther CPEC PhD from the
Paracelsus Medical University Institute
of synergetics and psychotherapy
research in Salzburg Austria my name is
Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots leopards is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have any troubles seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Shi Peck I will
now turn the presentation over to him I
am speaking to you from such a town of
Mozart and we go to the topic of pattern
transitions in mind and brain I have
three parts in this speech as the first
is on mathematical modeling of human
change dynamics at the psychological
level the second is on how to measure
change dynamics that is on internet or
app based monitoring and feedback in
psychotherapy and the third part is on
self-organization of mind and brain this
is a short report on our project at a
multi-level research on psychotherapy
change but first I will mention my
co-workers which are very important
persons here at our institutes and is Mr
Hammond Sheila and Katerina all PhD at
the Institute of synthetics and
psychotherapy user and co-workers in
Marseille France
that's a prostitue de negocios the
system professor togusa and also
professor market
Jakob University at Bremen someone is a
co-worker in our brain research and see
as we is a cooperation partner in our
mathematical projects now let's start
say a basic idea of investigating human
change dynamics is sense in human beings
and subsystems of movements like the
brain like you mental systems and so on
self-organizing systems so we
investigate you are interested in how
self-organization takes place in the
nonlinear complex systems and this meta
theoretical concept which exists from
synergetics or from kale steering can
now be applied to neural systems to
cognition emotion or behaviors and is to
psychology classical topics in
psychology and also to social systems
and this pattern transition pattern
formation in human in the actual systems
paths groups teams up to whose society
so this is a very interesting concept
such as principles and also some methods
which can be applied to self-organizing
systems and now we applied to quite
different systems substrates are
completely different but the concepts in
phenomena and the methods are identical
I will start with a mathematical model
of change dynamics in psychotherapy up
to now we have a lot of knowledge how
psychotherapy works at the level of
ingredients or single factor factors
which contribute to successful more or
less successful second Europeans but
what we don't have up to now our models
which integrate these factors and which
allow for an understanding of the
interconnectedness of the factors and of
the nonlinear interactions of these
vectors and this was the starting point
of a project which tried to model human
change processes at mathematical level
for doing since we introduced five
variables so which is tried and produce
change this is the intensity and the
level of problems or symptoms in unity
here it's called P motivation for change
and successes said is said therapeutic
progress and the experience confident in
to progress by the patient inside that
is a degree patients try and are able to
understand what's going with problems
and symptoms and the intensity of
emotions that is high levels of CC
variable means
emotions are annoying and stressful and
lower levels are less stressful feelings
and feelings of joy and of easy
heartedness those hours in the country
winters and now we try to understand how
the interaction works and for this we
define and functions mathematical
functions which describe how the input
variable for example in this case
problem intensity creates motivation for
change
the idea is set at very low levels of
problems no stress no worry sir is no
need to be motivated to change anything
if problem intensity increases and the
intensity of motivation also increases
up to a specific level and after or
beyond his level of problem intensity
motivation decreases because people have
no motivation to change such big
intensities of stress or problems that
is something like hopelessness or
helplessness and see intensity houses
function increases versus current point
is placed and say phase of this turning
point this depends on parameters which
correspond to personality traits or
dispositions in this kind in this kind
this position to be motivated or hope
forward to Kant old infant with very
intense problems and if this parameter M
is very low so persons have no hope and
no revoir expect
the factory is very low even high or low
levels of problems do not create any
motivation for change and you say an
parameter is very high a person have
four expectations of being fully capable
to solve problems and to cope with
stress the level since is the green
value is very high and only very rarely
intense problem intensities right can in
turn versus cells a shape is defined but
see concrete shape of this factory
depends on personal motive of personal
dispositions as you see a logic of the
system and we have 16 functions
described in house variables or in terms
of penetrants all the parameters
interact I cannot explain all the
functions because it was really very
very big story perhaps only one as a
function could be explained so this
relationship from problem or stress
intensity to worrying or negative
emotions if you have very high
competences in helping with emotions
emotion regulation capacities and very
high regard expectations and
[Music]
dispositions for coping with stress
since it's a green curve so even higher
levels of problem intensity or stress do
not create very intensive negative
emotions and so with low or negative
intense problems emotions go down that
is this creates positive emotions this
would be healthy answers would be
very flexible way of coping with
problems if since these positions are
lower since a blue curve of course that
is with increasing levels of expressing
emotions increase and later on she can
be coped and he read both shows with
very low competencies in emotional
regulation and hopeless attitudes to us
oneself also world very low problem
intensity small doses of press activate
very negative stressful emotions and
only these extreme levels can only code
by extreme behavior for example
self-harm or consuming drugs or even
suicidal attempt that it's a basic
mechanism for example of all the land
personality how we have sixteen of these
functions which are interrelated by five
nonlinear equations see parameters the
control parameters in terms of
synergetics and personality traits in
terms of psychology are the therapeutic
alliance or basic option to attach to
other cognitive competencies
metallization and emotional regulation
behavioral resources and trade
motivation since these positions
maybe eight and to moderate the
interactions in nonlinear interaction
between set variables in terms of
energetics say all the parameters and in
terms of psychology state so she's
really a was maybe integrated estates
the parameters straight this is matrix
which shows modifying or moderating
effects of the parameters on functions
between variables or all the parameters
the individual disposition forces is
based on two drains which moderate
effect rj5 tablet equation differential
equations so since it's a discrete model
with lot of nonlinear interactions and
is the reason lysis equations and create
arrows and in a certain region of
parameter intensity indeed dynamics is
coyote you see the dynamics of five
variables here are dynamics embedded in
the three dimensional phase space which
is created by time delay coordinate so
you see really beautiful and typical
strange attractors or chaotic attractors
and here on the right you have a
specific effect of chaotic dynamics this
is sensitive dependency of the dynamics
on the initial conditions and this is
so-called butterfly effect if you start
the system with almost the same initial
values of the variables with in
comparatively short period of time
two dynamics will exponentially emerge
and run in the concrete different way
this is a picture on before cave of p4k
from diagrams on x-axis of these
diagrams you have very small steps of
increasing parameters parameter AC is
the attachment or therapeutic alliance
cognitive competencies behavioral
resources and trait motivation so you
increase your parameters SPECT I step in
a very very small steps and on the y
axis you see also values time series of
variables for example success which is
realized over a longer period of time at
one end the same moment or one at the
same value of the control parameter you
see these actress which shows that
really you have many realizing realized
values at one in the same parameter and
then you change the parameter a little
bit and you have other's values and
these are sees before patient diagrams
which are really critical for ensuring
stability mechanism of up to this moment
the systems around really deterministic
and there is no fluctuation or noise
terms added Ponce's and on it what we
see is that at the specific level of
separators here we have C programming to
see at the specific level of 0.5
specific dynamics is created a chaotic
dynamics which is represented by this
chaotic attractor and at an
in this period you get quite another but
also Celtic attractor and in between we
change the parameter continuously
successively continuously from one value
to another a little bit higher value we
see some kind of phase transitions
theories say attractors change straight
from one to the other and this is
exactly what's in the chat ascribes we
can continuously control parameters in
this case we have four and we get a
discontinuous jump of C realized all the
parameter dynamics that is what we call
a phase or all the transition of
equations which describes the evolution
of the cultural parameters the control
parameters or something like rates or
dispositions which themselves can
undergo an evolution by new experiences
change behavior change emotions which
change also on the long term as dynamics
of variables and citrate so we have so
we have poles and both interact say
states create changes in traits and vice
versa and say all the parameter dynamics
creates an evolution of the control
parameters six hours equations which
describes dynamics of the control
parameters at the slower time scale and
indeed each in psychology we can see
said the evolution of traits and its
personality
development takes place at the lower and
slower time scale and opinions of
citrate so we have those and comes
together since they trades dynamics
spectra interaction explained some
personality change which was created by
psychotherapy the smaller produces some
very interesting dynamics I told about
all the transitions this is a sudden or
instantaneous come to another attractor
which corresponds to which was called
happy gains or losses and we can also
see that even Norris can create all the
transitions which is possible and his
corresponds who's affected treatments or
interventions don't play such an
important role as we thought up now what
we see here in this diagram is the fact
that under specific conditions the
dynamics of the variables create
critical instabilities and it's a death
turbulent and say create instabilities
but the change in separates is not
sufficient to create reality really a
travel to another attractive Taji this
times relaxes back to the former
attractive and in another case so is
pacific threshold which is over down
budget great and the system can is
continually travel to another track so
the symptom severity and the intensity
of stressful emotions decreases and
success and motivation for change
increases only here from all the
transition asymmetry break fast here
and his system reaches a new level of
citrate so which can be understood as a
personality development and interactions
yourself organized threshold between
control and other parameters or States
and traits reaches and over those
self-organized threat of this concept of
they're organized threshold threshold is
really important in understanding why
and under which conditions therapeutic
change may be stable and sustainable and
in other cases relapses back use this is
a long-term simulation we can do
simulation status with this model now so
it is a system which has very high
levels of symptoms abilities which is
Arab proof and negative emotions also
and then to person undergoes longer
treatment perhaps in a hospital during a
hospital stay and we put interventions
on all five variables in during this
period fancy interventions so perhaps
the person is released from inpatient
treatment and so it's a really intensive
rebound effect acceptance immunity
immediately increases but only one kind
of intervention see is on emotions for
this perhaps such things as
antidepressant drugs which continue
those emotions are reduced for this
person this continues for a specific
time but this creates a stage which
produces a very low motivation for
change now inside
and goes down and successes though on
the long term really are sustainable and
stable effects of the psychotherapy is
created we can validate this kind of
model because all traits and all
variables or all parameters can be
measured by an internet-based system by
a specific questionnaire which was
developed and if we compare related time
with the empirical dynamics of a
specific patient we see a very amazing
similarity of empirical dynamics of
these five variables and the related
dynamics which is created by a
mathematical computer simulation
especially the similarity goes up to
high correlations if we respect
experienced interventions or she
experienced events during a day which
can trigger the emotions and symptoms
immunity or inside of the patient so
itself experienced input on Tuesday
system as it is seen by the patient if
we respect his input vector sense
similarity is really high and the
correlations
a really very high between simulation
and the computer model here we have a
small losing on to the variable applied
a gliding averaging window of only three
measurement points the fifth is the
story of say computer simulation in the
future we hope that we can use this
computer system for training
psychotherapists they can understand how
complex nonlinear dynamics is working
and also in connecting and implementing
some mathematical model into our
monitoring system the next step here is
on how to measure change dynamics in
real-world systems that is in
psychotherapy piece which are running in
the hospital inpatient treatment or in
outpatient psychotherapies and what we
see if we apply an app or internet-based
systems is so called energetic
navigation system to our patients which
was done in several thousands cases
meanwhile since more than one decade we
which show exact is his well-known
butterfly effect the sensitive
dependency of the dynamics of the
initial conditions in all three diagrams
we superimpose three times user which
are from from three different clients in
each diagram wings which start almost at
the same values for the first one two
three four iterations probation
endpoints and transit system starts to
be worse they go into quite different
directions and
if we know that another case started at
the same values is not happy or
predicting selenium on run services
they're sensitive dependency on the
dynamics on very small differences in
the usual conditions see butterfly
effect also in real life systems of
psychotherapists which means and indeed
these systems cannot be predicted on the
long terms are nonlinear and they are
able to create all the transitions by
themselves not from the outside but
really self-organized
the system we use is at base or
internet-based it's a server based
system which has several different
questionnaires available a specific
process questionnaire the therapy
process questionnaire which was
developed by our own team and quite
different outcome questionnaires or
symptom questionnaires for all kinds of
disorders and diagnosis and it's also
possible to create individualized
questionnaires together with the best
here's a picture of C AB have available
so the system is used for creating
collecting data for visualizing the data
in some times and for the analysis time
series analysis of these processes those
approach development project of the
trend is measured and monitored by the
synergetic navigation system and the
system feeds back the dynamics
visualizes the dynamics
and since feedback is tank of control
because it's a continuous cooperative
process control because the results are
continuously shown who declined and
discussed with the therapist so by using
which kind of danger monitoring and
visualization of the dynamics to system
supports and catalyzes the personal
development growth rate of decline time
to you is like actions usually is the
time in terms of phase one measurement I
and y-axis so co ordinate shows the
intensity of different values here we
have see factors of therapeutic progress
in one client and the intensity of
mindfulness and self-care assets another
factor of paying client and easier real
nice for example of an older transition
here we have critical instabilities and
here we have to be focus and sit down
into quite another page we can
superimpose this time series different
items from one questionnaires of a
patient different factors which are
created by the system or even from
different person so for example capital
severity we can to bring those time
series of fellows partners of a couple
Indian physical evolution of this diet
of persons what is assumed in many
publications from colleagues all all
over the world is that psycho therapist
or animal
human change processes are running on on
a standard trick if you make an average
time series from different clients for
example of specific diagnosis you can
create by statistical means overall or
ever reached mean times use which is
called a standard track and persons
should move up to see a sample of many
colleagues on such under threat and who
use out of Thunder tracks is at risk of
deterioration or at risk of drop out if
you now create such a standard track
time few citizens right line here in the
middle and comparing to the real-time
series of specific individual clients we
see that real-time views are almost
always out of such standard tracks say
have higher values and they have lower
values and since higher levels also are
necessarily because it's indicate
critical instabilities which are
precursors of all the pattern
transitions in self-organizing systems
and if we compare an intensity of
[Music]
Aviation's of the time series from
substandard track and correlatives to
specific outcome measures these are the
sub scale of icd-10 based symptom rating
depression anxiety obsessive compulsive
disorder somatoform disorder eating
disorder and so on we see no
correlations that are thick gray cells
some values are not significant
correlation menus or even
you see a positive correlation sexy
intensity of evasions from the standard
track correlate positively with outcome
which can be explained by the theory of
self-organization all the transitions
and critical instabilities and also
chaotic dynamics never ran understand
the track and Aviation's from standard
tricks are important for creating
positive feedback now what is possible
with this suna traffic navigation system
is to work in a very personalized way
personalized psychotherapy now is so one
of the most important development in
evolution ways we have now because a
casino in former times was organized
schools confessions of psychotherapy
Center where treatment or add knows
specific programs treatment programs for
depression for anorectic or eating
disorders or for passive compulsive
disorders and so on and now actually we
are running see way of personalized
psychotherapy said is we do very
detailed test formulations and Francie's
case from formulations we can track the
change dynamics by individualized
questionnaires and we can tailor and
indesign psychotherapy proceeding
proceedings to the clients through the
actual stage of his dynamics since
picture cells said we can create case
formulations in terms of these video
graphic system models which are
developed together with the clients as a
longer procedure
and said we can define two variables
equal conditions emotions behaviors
which are important for understanding a
specific problem for client and the
interactions between these variables
this is results in such kind of system
models and we take the variables which
are really specific to the situation of
a client to this problem and transform
it into visual analogs Hales two items
of a personalized questionnaire and we
see items we can create the dynamics as
many items as such kind of system as
variables and we can refer as to the
model and to the time series during the
sessions so during the psychotherapy
sessions clients and therapists are
looking at the screen where we can see
the dynamics and so relate what they are
saying intent to do to the system model
this is a geographic system models with
specific individualized personalized
change dynamics so psychotherapy is an
integrative big loop system the basic
actual perceptions actions which are
fundamental and important for our
everyday life and our intended behavior
our feelings and our thinking and our
natural environment very self
assessments by the app or subjective
navigation system such a reflect on what
has what goes on in emotions or emotion
regulation and so on on a specific day
then we can have a look at the dynamic
in the therapy session session by
session together with the zebrafish and
we can visualize the dynamics in the
screen in specific diagram it's kind of
measurement and self assessment month
per day for perhaps 10 or 15 minutes
also is the option to write electronic
Diaries as specific effects on the
syllabus for example you can see and
identify patterns which could not be
seen without his computer technique the
dynamics all the transitions chaotic
dynamics changing synchronization
between cognitions and emotions have
nots equality of variances can not
really be seen in real situations by
looking at the client this has no taste
and has no specific optics expect for we
make it physical by computer to it this
helps for adaptive indications and is a
data drive of decision on what kind of
interventions and next steps could be
useful in the psychotherapeutic process
this gives confidence to the syllabus
and since relates his work this is
clinically work to series in this case
to the series of summer sandwich attics
and it's all self organizing dynamic
system the side of the patient feedback
by the computer tool gives confirmation
of the CEO to reputed browsers come from
such surveys really good
this is confidence and safety to the
client it's a valid feedback the
emotions and cognitions as
it fascism rates by himself our
one-to-one reflected by the methods and
visualized this enhances motivation for
change six gives an experience of
self-efficacy what I do has really
consequences this enhances
self-regulation
of behavior and emotions in baking which
helps to learn how cope with and control
innate notions and during assessment ten
minutes per day for example patients
learn to differentiate between quite
different emotions and in mental states
and it helps to perceive emotions and
ceases a process of learning mental
conditions by mindfulness metal hoops on
one's own consciousness why we do
measurements one once per day can be
illustrated by these slides which come
with which are coming out since light
indicates that we have specific patterns
which are transformed by human change
processes see here for example and
emotions its grief paid by day until a
specific day of about forty five days of
hospital stay there are intense
fluctuations learning turbulent
experience emotions and sentry pattern
is completely changed and if we take if
we take only English second the
measurement point sees patterns
starts to
this appear here we see the fluctuations
a little bit but on a smaller degree and
if you take image forest measurement
point since Pacific pattern the pattern
transition of intensive fluctuations to
low fluctuations is a beautiful it's
about every seventh measurement point
that is an assessment once per week and
as I assessment once per week exactly
same data but other days this is all two
weeks for smartly measurement and we can
get the impression sets his grief
intensity changes to a lower level to an
increased level or remains completely
unchanged so it really depends on when
we measure and we have to define a
specific measure mannerism which up to
our experience is very good for do this
once per day what we see is this kind of
all the transition here you see a
specific pattern of the head of a
quadrant and this changes and to a
critical instability is reached and sand
turns to a tepee order transition we
call it the Bavarian way of all the
traditions exactly sees all the
transitions which are prepared by a
critic instability can be seen in
sympathetic navigation system such what
we see in many cases is we find a
running window on certain theories and
running or gliding window
the amplitude of the time series the
frequency of changes anti distribution
of C values over C point a and what we
see in many cases set at the specific
period of the change process sustained
any complexity it's really increased
there is something like a peak of critic
instability and some is reduced and
situation also it's reduced in this
picture we have each line as a time
series of a specific item of pain
questionnaire and at this period we see
increased instability yellow orange and
red colors increased critical
instabilities during a specific and
limited period of time after this period
the dynamics much karma and much reduced
exactly at this point of critic
instabilities also the symptom severity
and intensity here of survived ox
so you see Gail brown
obsessive-compulsive scale of an
obsessive-compulsive patient is
immediately and instantaneously reduced
to a lower dollar said is no linear
process but this process is exactly what
we can see in each case our results
[Music]
difference between of the dynamic
complexity over say complete process the
maximum of these Peaks is this maximum
difference which is so my axis of these
diagrams
directly corresponds or correlates with
symptom reduction once y-axis we have on
the x-axis here we have reduced symptoms
immunity of 94 patients of a study we
realized some years ago and we see that
the intensity of the critic instability
correlates up 2.6 with symptom
reductions and is responsive outcome
with treatment thickness in the cases
where as symptoms immunity did not
change but increase this correlation is
not events it is not realized we have no
correspondence between the intensity of
critical instability steering she
changed roses and sciatica in another
study we could see sets he a peak of
secreting instability occurs just before
Singh main interventions starts and this
in his treatment of the study
obsessive-compulsive disorder patients a
flooding or exposure with response
prevention intervention treatment was
realized and started for each patient at
a specific moment during the hospital
stay and what we saw said see critic
instabilities as you after this into
intervention was realized
but before and also the symptom severity
decreased before the intervention was
started this is very astonishing and
amazing if you will expect such a
treatment realises the order transition
or triggers he order transition and also
see critically instabilities of the of
therapeutic process since is
evidently not the case significance the
beauties appeal before and create the
outcome in our study results at the
intensity of a local complexities is the
phenomenon of critic instabilities low
complexity high complexity creates more
outcome in terms of semitone reduction
music reductive of the why box is in
lines and another important point is
said client who experienced a good
emotional climate at sea board a twister
therapists and other patients cruel
patients fellow patients realize better
outcomes in terms of image ethics this
is an effect of stable boundary
conditions which are necessary for the
destabilizing processes of self
organized changes so therapeutic change
human development is something like this
double ization within the context of
stability both is necessary and if Bo's
is given we get the best results of
fluency outcomes as well and as a
symptom measure one factor of this
European process questionnaire with more
or less the same result what we identify
at s precursor of critical instabilities
and it's pattern transitions it's not
overly critical instabilities and the
dynamics of many cognitions and emotions
but also an increased synchronization
between the
items of a process questioner said his
emotions and cognitions are synchronized
and these increased synchronization may
be an indicator of Psychopaths
pathological States and also and
precursor of phase transitions during
the processes you see absolute ever
reached correlations between all items
of this process question else's line and
you see the decrease just at the moment
of a phase transition also specific
stress Xperia T and practices as a
subsequent depression anxiety stress
came are increased just before the
pattern transition takes place this is a
picture of one patient's that
dissociative disorder identity patient
and what we see is set items or
conditions emotions which refer to a
specific ego state in this case to a
child ego state of these patients are
highly synchronized positively
correlated which is indicated by the
green colors and also see items
cognitions emotions which should refer
to an outer stage is an adult competent
state ego state observations these
cognitions emotions are also completely
synchronized but see items vice-versa
between the states are anti-correlated
which is shown by the red color of
correlation cities strong negative
correlations during fees period of time
as ego states dominate what success in
mental and psychological psychological
functioning of
patient and then after since transition
say pathologically over synchronization
which is dominated or enslaved by cease
to legal state sees a very straight
pattern enslaved by to order parameters
or ego states completely dissolves and
the correlations decrease the pattern is
dissolved and also the symptom severity
symptom intensity is coming to reduce so
we can see all the transitions or
outcome patterns of psychotherapy which
are not simply correlated to symptom
severity and any levels of some
questionnaires but which have to do with
pattern transition so we have proposed
differences assessed by Pacific scores
of questionnaires symptoms course at the
beginning high at the end very low but
we have also other indicators of
changing dynamics and of outcome for
example transition in the time series
patterns transitions in synchronization
patterns interitum correlation dynamics
which are shown is such kind of moving
into combination matrices and also phase
transitions as they can be show film by
recurrent plots which are methods which
indicate very clearly where phase
transitions you know specific dynamic
process with specific variables take
place now the last part of this speech
is on self-organization at the brain
level and related to self-organization
psychological measures multi level and
multi methods
project on circus here
we tried to grasp these different levels
of course by different methods one
method is a clinical impression we get
we get because we know the patient's
during the change process at the
hospital very well and an impression he
also gets by electronic Diaries
patients are writing on sir electronic
powering notebook the other level are
multiple time series which are rated
once per day by our synergetic
navigation system since our time series
from the 0p broseph's questionnaire and
the analysis methods are on dynamic
complexity correlation pattern dynamics
recurrence plots in this picture is once
again a complexity resonance diagram
versus vertical lines indicate critical
periods of critical instability at the
brain level we did repeated functional
magnetic imaging with summations that is
there underwent four to five fMRI
sessions during a three to four-month
hospital stay and we can have a look at
the activated brain regions and such
change of these activated brain regions
and modeling can be done by dynamically
causal model modeling for example that
is a method introduced by current wisdom
and co-workers on the effective
interconnectivity between specific not
so much as a number of
localizations is limited of course but
on specific connections and what you can
see is housing effective
interconnections between brain areas
affective connectivities are changing
during cirrhosis another method is
functional connectivity dynamics which
use a say chronic tone of brain and
arrives inter brain synchronization
matrix matrices here we have a matrix of
about 80 different brain regions and the
colors indicate the intensity of the
correlations between his full brain
model of more than 80 regions and
finally we assess biochemical markers in
the blood at each fMRI session or before
each memorization we took a little bit
of blood occupations in order to analyze
for neural plasticity markers like C
brain-derived neurotropic factor
dressing Decatur's s cortisol but also
zero - oxytocin and amethyst as intra
liking and two monthly growth factors so
we can start a bridge from qualitative
experiences of the clown to
psychological time series brain dynamics
and biochemical markers what we expect
here and we found in our study we
realized this is parenting is that the
brain activity changes exactly when the
critical instabilities in turn and
complexity occurs and is reduced so
biases maximum also dynamic complexity
we find all the transitions and we see
also in this patient of his brain study
the Y box measures his symptoms immunity
decreased immediately after say
Simonne intensity of dynamic complexity
and trust here from the first to the
second measure the brain activity was
completely changed later on when the
dynamics was reused and so central
finality most reviews and now critical
instabilities and all the transitions
took place several no specific and
significant changes in brain activity so
trust at the moment of all the
transitions in maximum of brain changes
also take place this was seen in nine
patients in a very similar way we
published this in 2013 in PLoS ONE paper
a very significant effect our actual
study we used besides provoking
stimulation parenting we used also
personalized pictures which we took in
the whole situation of the clients we
went with a digital camera to the
clients at home and took pictures versi
obsessions and compulsions will take
place in a home situation of the
patients and if we show these pictures
and compare it to neutral pictures of C
patients and also if we compare it to
standard pictures of ICD provoking
objects or situations we see a
combination of disorder specific
activities in the brain and also self
related activities of the brain are the
brain regions is unknown from some
midline structure
which indicate self related information
processes so this is really what we
wanted to see that is mineralised
pictures and situations trigger self
related information processing which
changes so is our hypothesis and
expectation which changes our say course
of treatment now actual brain research
is interested in connectivities of the
brain but this is not so easy to find
what we did in a review on all available
connectivity studies major depression is
to see if we can find some specific
substrates of connectivity switch
artists even for maker we investigated
about 60 studies and it was not so easy
to really integrate the results in order
to do this we identified 17 brain
regions and looked for sacral activities
and see result is a little bit
astonishing to sum up same methods
variance is bigger same gentleman
variant said it's depending on two
methods
EEG or functional MRI and assist
emulation parody for example tasks
related paradigms symptom provoking
triggers or resting states we have a lot
of different connectivities in this
matrix we see which how many studies
indicate for a decreased connectivity
between specific brain regions or
indicate
increased activity both occurs some
regions are more intensely
interconnected in patients and in
healthy controls and other regions are
decreased in activity and especially in
connectivity which also results for
arresting states dynamic sure you get
more significant results but you see
there are intensified connectivity
saying yellow bars here indicating
increased interconnectivity of a
specific brain region to others and see
turkeys bars indicating increased
connectivity so actually we cannot
simply say that the amygdala or say
prefrontal cortex or the only two
frontal cortex or to campus for other
regions are more or less interconnected
to each other in patients same healthy
controls one reason of a little bit
fussy virgin result is set these
dynamics are not quiet we are
continuously moving and this movement of
interconnectivity brain is quite fast
and at at least we have to to assess
this connectivity dynamics we have to
measure it we have to model it in fact
what we are now in our project together
with colleagues from our side a
festering user and his coworkers these
are for interconnecting mattresses of
eight brain areas now in
obsessive-compulsive disorder
see you in a yellow orange and red
colors intensive intensified
interconnections between specific brain
areas eight brain areas and his
interconnectedness is decreased if we
look at this for four different fMRI
sessions within resting state that is
not a task related or a still picture
stimulated provocation herding but ten
minutes of resting state whose closed
eyes and now what we can do is to
correlate this interconnection matrices
is a functional connectivity of each
brain regions over the time so we
analyze interconnectivity and let run
line in window over ten minutes of
resting state and Inter correlates a
correlation matrix so it'll be too
complicated to understand so is the
inter correlation of inter correlation
matrices between brain areas and if we
do this we can create a new connectivity
matrix which is called functional
connectivity dynamics because the matrix
shows directly in time by time matrix
how long the connectivity pattern
remains stable so these high
correlations between this snapshot
connectivity matrices fills that we have
periods with higher connectivity and
lower values of correlation between
matrices in turkeys and blue colors film
such the correlations are low so it's
lower stability
what we see for to patients and actually
we are analyzing this for 17 other
patients is hypothesis which can be
tested now that the stability of brain
activity big functional brain activity
between 80 different brain areas is
higher at the beginning set is an
indication of repetitive stable not
unflexible brain activity which perhaps
refers to ruminations or obsessions of
the patient answers red colored
thickness is stable interconnectivity
changes over time so the turquoise and
blue color stormy night say brain
activity and perhaps also two related
cognitive activity gets more and more
flexible patients can change cognitions
in 10 minutes of resting state and
hopefully also interesting life see an
idea of interconnection between
variables also was taken
forcing interaction between items of a
personal question error of patients you
can correlate say items say time series
which are created by altering the items
once per day and we can integrate these
matrices and sim van specific dynamics
of a system remain stable and subscribe
also very well to recurrence plot so
from the same questionnaire though we
have different ways of showing how
patterns in cognitive dynamics are
changing over the time
follows his forest same ideals said if
the correlation matrices themselves are
correlated and sisters
where's dynamics in this case of
questions which are owns at once per day
these patterns remain stable and get
into another kind of dynamics so this
should be a proof set we can understand
mental behavioral emotional processes
same theoretical concepts and also the
same methods despite we have quite
different measurement devices and
qualities of time series but imagine
this is easy analysis tools and basic
concepts of all the transitions of
critic instabilities of precursors of
changing synchronization succession
between these dynamics is quite similar
and since perhaps what science can
produce to reduce complexity by unifying
paradigms and unifying concepts at quite
different levels and qualities thank you
[Music]
thank you dr. Shi Peck for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 14 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye